hey guys how's it goin so today I'm
really excited because I'm going to be
unboxing something really fun for you
the question that I get all the time
from all of you guys it's just seeing
what equipment do I need to get started
to make youtube videos basically canon
has now answered that question for you
with their video creator kit this comes
with a canon t6i and it also comes with
a lens a microphone and an SD card and
let me tell you what I've bought so many
different cameras and the one thing they
never come with is an SD card and if it
does come with an SD card it's like a 16
gigabyte one which is not gonna get you
very far so this one actually comes with
a 32 gig so let's start with the
unboxing a shall we so like I said this
is the t6 I pretty excited because one
key thing that you want when you're
gonna be doing YouTube videos and your
shooting by yourself is you want to have
a flip up screen guess what flip out
screen also it will connect to Wi-Fi so
you'll be able to get any of your videos
and photos directly onto your phone
you'll also be able to control the
camera right from your smart phone what
can happen when phones become even
smarter than they are now we're gonna
call the smarter phones like what are we
gonna do I don't know this is freaking
perfect it comes with everything so I'm
really excited about this microphone I
have one of the smaller ones like this
so I've actually been wait a minute no
battery required are you joking what's
up with this in a second okay here we go
no that's too ate a lot of time some of
these cameras won't come with lenses
will guess watch this one does include
one and what's great about this is
you're gonna already have the body of
the camera and you could upgrade lenses
at any time well does that mean upgrade
the London's Justine so case you
actually have absolutely no idea what
I'm talking about this here is the 18 to
55 so this is determine how far your
zoom is and also your depth of field so
a lot of times I
love to have shots where everything is
sort of really out of focus in the
background because it looks a little bit
more artsy and also looks like a much
higher production value here is the body
over the camera line up blue dots twist
it in and help me you're ready to roll
so what I love most about DSLRs is being
able to change the lenses and so will
allow you to get a completely different
look and it's super simple as you guys
can see this does have one of the
flip-out reversible screens so when
you're filming and vlogging so it's
actually kind of light too so even if
you did want to use this as sort of a
handheld vlogging camera you could also
do that as well because you can see
yourself but as a recommendation do not
look at the screen when you're vlogging
it says it'll look like this you'll look
like you're looking off to the side and
everyone knows that you're looking at
yourself and it's awkward
carry on strap here so you cannot put
that on which I recommend putting on
immediately
nice little USB cable have you ever seen
one of these charger and battery this
right here anything else or I toss the
box aside no there we go along I don't
know why I'm putting this in here
because I'm gonna put it in here I like
where this camera's light your SD card I
destroy my room every single time I
unbox of anything where's the microphone
you guys are at VidCon please stop by
the cannon booth I'm going to be doing
some meetups there and doing some
vlogging talks look at you you look so
good sound like so you just plug the
microphone in it's right there on the
switch guys I just took your photo holy
crap that looks actually really good
video usage it's just a little video
option right there and I can't see my
face my screens flipped oh good so you
guys might notice that the white balance
is a little bit different on this camera
because I have the white balance
actually set according to my lighting
scheme and here it's a little bit
different because I haven't actually
touched any of the settings this is all
auto I just sort of turned it on so here
we go let's see I don't know what to say
actually other than I'm pretty excited
I'm glad that this is light because it's
light enough but this is something that
I feel like I can actually hold and walk
around and vlog with I know what you
guys think of this camera let me know
what you guys used to vlog or film
actual sit-down videos there's so many
different options out there when it
comes to like choosing cameras and
choosing things that work for you so
really a lot of times you know just
getting something that you know what's
gonna work is most important especially
for me and I'm pretty excited about this
and I'm excited to see you guys at
VidCon so make sure you guys stop by I'm
so glad that they put together something
like this because having divided it in
separate most of the time is kind of
annoying
and I mean it's all in one freaking box
ready for you guys
so yeah I'm gonna go I'll talk to you
guys later make sure you like this video
and let me know if there's anything else
that you would like to know about
vlogging or cameras or equipment and
stuff that I use in general so that's it
I'll see you later bye
[Music]